pic alors je vous explique à tous les
trois et aux téléspectateurs comment
grâce à une cravate
j'ai enfin pu obtenir l'accord de john
le carré de venir ici
c'était il y à qu'a pris il y a deux ans
nous étions tous les deux parce que nous
étions rompre et compenser tous les deux
edwards pardon john le carré parce que
vous vous receviez la récompense d'un
écrivain européen et moi comme
journalistes européens et je suis arrivé
le samedi soir très en retard le dîner
était commencé et je me suis dit est ce
que je veux une cravate ou prou pas puis
je me suis dit quand même et les
italiens sont très élégants j'ai donc
mis une cravate je suis arrivé repas il
y avait 200 personnes repas offert par
les éditeurs italiens et je le suis
aperçu qu'aucun homme ne portait une
cravate d'en vendre mais la mienne et je
les mises dans ma poche
le lendemain à l'hôtel de ville de capri
on remet les prix j'arrive je n'ai pas
de cravate
tous les hommes avec une cravate alors
je me remets d'abord ma récompense
et puis je fais un petit laïus de
remerciement et jeudi deux choses je dis
d'abord je raconte l'histoire d'un
cravate puisque j'étais débraillé et
jeudi regardez john le carré lui c'est
un vrai anglais il connaît les usages il
connaît les le savoir vivre et il avait
une cravate il sait quand il faut mettre
une cravate et il sait quand il ne faut
pas mettre une cravate moi je ne le sais
pas en bon français et puis la deuxième
chose que j'ai dit c'est que j'avais un
peu de scrupules à recevoir ce prix
puisque j'avais devant moi quelqu'un qui
monterait à lui tout seul les limites de
mon émission puisque ça venait des
années des années qu'ils refusaient d'y
passer
et alors à ce moment là john le carré a
eu un geste magnifique il a fait ceci il
a fait ça l'a retiré sa cravate
à ce moment là nous avions tous les deux
le col ouvert
il me l'a montré il m'a dit il suffira
de me montrer ceci et je viendrai votre
émission
et cette cravate c'est la vôtre vous
m'aviez offert k2 mais vous pouvez le
vote merci d'écouter ça me fait un très
très bon souvenir et donc ben voila j'ai
fait une émission sans cravate qui va me
changer